foreign
people they think the Cure and the
problem the fix for the problem is will
give me more money I'm gonna be all
right but the more you make the more you
spend right if you have no discipline
and no structure yes absolutely every
time yes every time well just give me
more and more no the more you get the
more you're going to spend and people
ain't gonna listen because we are caught
up in looking a certain way living a
certain way trying to appease others who
don't really care nothing about you yeah
he has to say oh I got it wow
I got a two and a half almost 30 years I
didn't say what 80 83 percent of my
salary I don't need validation from
nobody on the outside that's another
downfall in society we always need
validation exceptions from others don't
try to live a lifestyle that you know
you can't afford right you can't you
can't you can't do that
all right so you got a pro football
player it said in the in the in the copy
there
he flew Spirit Airlines instead of
chartering a jet this guy made millions
and millions and millions yeah right
um instead of flying Southwest I'm
flying Spirit right I mean fake jewelry
the whole thing
he's like man I I don't have to prove
myself to everybody I love it I love it
I've been guilty of that I've been
guilty of being in situations where I
feel like I have to prove like I belong
here and the way to prove I belong is by
you know having the same the same bag
she has having the same shoes they have
and if you do that it's like a status
thing but it's so deeply rooted in
insecurity it really is like that's not
and I heard him say on another part of
the interview too like that's not what
gives you your worth like what you can
buy are you kidding me yeah so I really
I mean I love that it makes me think of
that scripture one person pretends to be
rich yet has nothing
and another pretends to be poor but has
great wealth
I mean what do you want to do you want
to you want to be fake rich or real Rich
you know what I'm saying and I just I I
like what he said this show is a lot
about
um like exact ratios and what's the
exact percentage before I do this and
the ratio before I do this and this yeah
and so I don't want to get caught up in
the in the numbers here but saving 80 of
his income yes he's extreme well but
he's also making millions and millions
yeah and I I have been guilty of the he
was exactly right yeah I've spent my
entire career my thinking well if I just
made some more money then fill in the
blank and what ends up happening is my
house is gotten a little bit bigger my
car's gotten a little bit nicer and I
and I realized a few a few jobs ago this
just never stops until I stop it the
goal post keeps moving every single time
see what I did there yes I see what you
did there okay well played so don't try
to live a lifestyle you can afford yeah
here's the hard truth of this it's easy
to look at at Ochocinco and say okay
he's worth millions and millions
so what we are saying and I'll say you
can join me or not
if you make sixty five thousand dollars
as a teacher
you've chosen a Corolla life and that is
okay you've chosen a Camry life until
yeah you can like was it the the third
the third job that's that's a
Millionaire right there's engineers and
something else in teachers yep that's
right
um on the list so you can get there
absolutely but you don't get to decide
well I I want to have an 80 000 Suburban
which is used by the way right when
yours take home salary 65 000 like we
have to live relative to the job we make
instead of trying to live a lifestyle
that we can't afford I mean I definitely
think yeah for him saving 83 percent of
his income looks totally different than
like you said a teacher somebody who's
making an average salary it's not the
same I mean I don't save 83 percent of
my income are you kidding me like you
I'd be wearing a cardboard box right now
so well and I know there's teachers
across the country that just rolled
their eyes when I said 65 000 like I
don't know what teachers makeup not that
yeah but it's it's when you
let me just say it this way
stop trying to pretend to live somebody
else's life if you've made the choice to
have job X or job y or it's the only job
you get that's fantastic and be so proud
of yourself be grateful of the
contribution you're making
and live that lifestyle absolutely yeah
you've gotta it's it points to
contentment and again I feel like we do
have to highlight the ratios because
it's a lot easier for him to quote it's
easy to say oh it's easier for him to
live on 20 he's got millions but to his
point the the like we said the goal post
is always moving and it's interesting
because you're always comparing yourself
to what's around you like I was watching
something I think it was Kevin Hart and
he was talking about you know if you're
on a a basketball team or a football
team you're hanging out with those guys
they're not all making the same money
that's right but it's a difference
between if you're like first string and
if you're like I don't know like the
Sixth Man or like over on the on the
sidelines and we're talking hundreds of
thousands if not millions of dollars
difference right in Pay right so it's
like hey after the game we're all going
out yeah really like you're not doing
what the quarterback's doing and it's
the same thing in our our own life if I
go out with a bunch of folks it's easy
to think hey we're all here we can all
afford the same same things and you
can't that's right I mean how many times
you go to dinner with people and it's
like hmm well they ordered the steak I
guess well maybe I'll order it too like
and you start changing your your
behavior based on who you're around you
go to work you start looking at the cars
in the parking lot oh well there well
maybe I need that too and you start
comparing yourself but you don't know
you don't know their life you only know
your life and you're the one that's got
to sleep at night that's exactly right
and we often don't understand that
somebody's mom passed away and left them
a bunch of money okay or somebody's
Granddad passed away and left them a
house or somebody else is struggling and
that's why they drive that car because
they don't care about this dumb
depreciating asset on Wheels they're
more interested in saving your college
funds we just make all sorts of stories
up about or people in the parking lot
next to us yeah stop yeah
I just live your life uh all right let's
go to the second one um he has a part
two to this um roll it James
but everybody's caught up in image and
looking a certain way and being rich
it's me
it's pointless you know how hard it is
to live like that all the time
consistently and be fly every day Drury
and listen
Heirs of rappers
think about the era before before us
right everybody was flashy stunned and
stunned and after 10 years what happens
oh you can't it's impossible to sustain
right it's impossible
oh I love that he's talking about
athletic culture hip-hop culture because
78 of athletes are losing their wealth
within three years and it's because of
the culture more bags Gucci belts you
know bottle service you know Maseratis
like Bentleys like this is the culture
I'm so glad that somebody's talking
about that telling us that it's not
necessary this is not what's giving us
our wealth rappers are not the people
who tell us how we have to dress John
Jay-Z don't tell you what car you have
to drive okay John he does he texted me
the other day and told me I should get
some new clothes and so